hey boss
this happened to me in Iraq Ambush
initiated by an RPG you would not be
standing in the middle of the street
shooting back hi I'm John Spencer I'm
the chair of urban Warfare studies at
the Modern War Institute I spent over 25
years in the U.S army but I've been
studying Urban Warfare for over a decade
today we're going to be looking at Urban
Warfare and movies and TV and judge how
real they are
[Music]
it's very accurate to be behind a wall
when you pop out for a second to throw a
grenade like that where you're still in
the grenade is a little off grenades
have a timer in them basically so they
don't blow up in your hand once it hits
the target it's not thorough explode
100 percent air support is that
vulnerable in urban operations and why
usually you don't bring it in it's low
flying it's slow it doesn't have much
protection and usually drop soldiers
offset of the urban battle in this
situation they didn't expect that level
of resistance
cross industry can actually be one of
the most vulnerable things of urban
Warfare because there's so many angles
so many windows so many doorways which
you can get shot so we teach things like
throwing smoke out so that people can't
see you and going one at a time and
mixing up the speed of which you're
going if I didn't know this battle the
battle of Mogadishu I would say that
this is not realistic where you have
hundreds of people shooting at a small
unit but that's really what happened and
they got the soldiers pretty accurate
but there's been a lot of criticism
about this movie and the depiction of
the somalis and kind of the context of
what what's going on in Mogadishu at
this time
[Music]
[Applause]
actually an iconic scene when he says
stay off the walls that was a real
advice because once the bullets are
hitting the walls then they travel down
the wall kind of like a bowling alley
and it can hit if you're standing on
that I wouldn't say it happens in all
because every city is different in your
mud and cement glass metal is a little
different but that's real
let's go
you see the bullet holes in the glass
because back then we we weren't as
prepared for urban Warfare as we are
today so those aren't bulletproof
Vehicles a lot of the weapons there
aren't really ready for that environment
that they're moving into but they also
were surprised by what they encountered
so I'd give it a like a nine from
realism in urban Warfare not realism and
the portrayal of the population and
things are going on
Chris Hemsworth is more like Jason
Bourne there with his hand-to-hand Close
Quarters fighting is very common to
Urban Warfare we actually tie the
weapons to ourselves so if we're get
caught in that situation and turn a
corner or somebody grabs our weapon they
can't take it away from us but not the
tactics that you're seeing in that scene
because he's surrounded by people with
bigger guns um so he's trying to disarm
one while another one's there personally
I would have tried to disarm one of them
with one of those rifles and then get
your back against something so you're
not expecting a bad guy at 360 degrees
and then incapacitate them in some way
I can't say I found myself in a similar
situation or we teach that but it could
work absolutely slow the person down buy
yourself some time I'd say you'd want to
turn Corners as much as possible and
especially in a building like that just
to confuse them on which way you went
out of everything out of that scene
that's probably the most realistic the
fact that he's hiding behind a column
that column is a supporting column so it
has steel reinforced Concrete where some
walls are you can be paper thin it could
be plaster if you don't have that then
you do get behind things like furniture
and other things anything you can to try
to get you covered yeah it was a lot of
fun to watch but I'd give it about a
Wonder or two in realism
I actually love this clip and I wish I
could show it to more soldiers to think
about buildings differently especially
if you're defending a house you want to
take the stairways away you want to take
the doors away and absolutely throw
furniture down but the scene is really
great too because it shows you that
that's not necessarily what you stay
behind to protect you from bullets
because bullets pass through wood
through cloth and everything
that's a great lesson that clip teaches
you that we teach our soldiers to stay
away from Windows you crouch down to go
underneath them kind of slowly walk your
way around them bullets incoming
probably wouldn't be that dramatic but
like that absolutely we tell you to stay
away from Windows
[Music]
that clip is is really important to what
people don't even think about even in
the military called Mouse holding
putting holes in walls and Floors to
move throughout the without being seen
it's very common in major Urban battles
actually I I would love for soldiers to
carry an ax or something like that but
there are other ways to do it sometimes
we use explosives
sledgehammers axes like that to make
that whole real tactics rule everything
so I'm going with a nine on that
actually
I mean this scene seems very familiar to
me because I had my own deployments to
Iraq into Baghdad where we're doing
raids like these where there's only a
few terrorists in the population of
Millions for the advantage of your
equipment you can see at night but also
to reduce the risk of being observed and
the risk to civilians the fact that
their their night vision goggles are
always on top of their head is not
realistic you'd want to cut the power or
eliminate the light sources so you want
to use those goggles to your advantage
foreign
it's very common and very smart to have
a sniper with OverWatch who has angles
that the people moving into the house
can't see it's a really good call for
the sniper to be the one to execute the
first shot because you want to save your
surprise to the last moment and the
snipers usually have the silenced weapon
this sniper in particular he'd probably
be wearing more more equipment and
usually it's a sniper and a spotter so
there'd be other people with him
the way they enter this house is a very
common almost too common thing that's
portrayed in movies it's called enter
and clear room throwing a grenade can be
the preferred tactic if it's known to be
an enemy location and you know there's
somebody in with a weapon of course
you're going to enter it with something
other than your face so the way they're
stacked on the door is about getting in
there quickly they actually evolved from
SWAT tactics these tactics were actually
developed to limit that amount of
violence because there may be civilians
intermixed in there
foreign
Cooper employing theirs what I would
teach want to get behind something
that's going to stop the bullets that
people are shooting at you but also be
able to return fire we call that cover
the windows are great to get down behind
kneel Behind still shoot from unlike the
enemy in that scene running out into the
open areas that's actually the opposite
of what actually happens they're going
to stay inside the rooms make you come
in there you know get off the streets in
the alleysers
on the move
when he goes off by himself and chases
that's not realistic we don't move by
ourselves anywhere it's almost like a
cardinal rule so it would be another
team person right there with them in
communicating to each other using some
type of radio or something if he says
moving and then somebody else would
follow him out there I give it a rating
of around an eight
Bush this happened to me in Iraq Ambush
initiated by an RPG ambushes are very
very common in urban Warfare It's meant
to surprise that people entrap them in a
a funnel like that although the bad guys
don't usually just stand on top of the
roof
come on
[Music]
you would not be standing in the middle
of the street shooting back you wouldn't
last long we'd seek cover use those
armored vehicles which is great ideally
though in the whole situation it's
called a Kill Zone of the Ambush you
want to get out of it
it's up of having a we call it a quick
reaction force a backup team because
you've been surprised somebody needs to
come to help you and we usually keep
forces in their uniform ready to go in
an urban setting like this to be that
quick reaction force to come to that Aid
they rammed the vehicle which is very
common trying to lock them in that kill
zone so everybody can shoot at you so
I'm actually going to give it a higher
rating than I want to because the Ambush
is so uh real outside of the tactics so
I'll give it up let's give it a four
the drones are probably the most
ubiquitous change to Urban warfare
that's happened in decades as I go into
Ukraine to research Urban Warfare right
now and the major battles there's
thousands and thousands of drones being
used it reduces some of the challenges
of urban Warfare if I can put a drone in
front of the soldier to see around that
corner to see over that building the
aspect of x-ray vision we're not there
yet because we still can't see through
concrete especially not much can see
through Steel
they gave me a lot of feelings of of
real stuff that's happened especially
the use of the dump truck reminds me of
the Beirut bombings where a dump truck
was brought to the front of the base
like in that scenario but then exploded
this is why Urban Warfare is so hard
your dump truck could be a thread
although that's probably unlikely that
you're going to use your vibranium
Shield to throw it up in the air but
what it signatures me is that what we
call a three block war where when you're
fighting an Urban Terrain you are
actually very concerned about the
civilian population and protecting
people at the same time as you're
fighting and there's restrictions on
what you can or can't do so you know
that's a very plausible scenario that
any soldier who has a has values is
trying to protect the civilian
population while still trying to do it
the mission so if the rating has to be
for realism I'll give it around a six
foreign
a couple little things in there there
are nice touches of adding realism to
the situation like the Red Dot that you
see on your scopes on the modern weapons
that will kind of help you aim to the
green Hue that you see on their eyeballs
they're coming out the night vision
goggles so when you see some version of
night vision goggles you got a martian
type of look when you look around
everybody's got green eyes look to the
top of this building let's go it's
blocked by buildings we got no vantage
point this Roost is a bust in this scene
they enter a really strong building like
that it's a great a great idea the
strategy was called strong points or a
building that is really strong it has
lines of sight or directions you can
fire from in multiple directions and in
war it's happened where a single
building has been held for months just
because of the it was the right strong
point he says it's a bus because
depending on what type the direction the
building where the enemy is
they got up there thought they'd have a
good vantage point but they couldn't see
anything so it was a bust
on your right
what we usually see in urban Warfare
movies is everybody trying to get to the
roof because it kind of is common sense
that I can shoot down I can see people
farther out but depending on the context
you don't want to be anywhere near the
roof because you can also be seen from
the air from drones from mortars you can
be hit it's based on a real situation
that happened in 2012 uh Benghazi where
they're attacking the embassy compound
that's a good idea to get up there so
you can see where they're coming from
and to take better shots and not waste
ammo from the rooftop for sure I give
that a pretty high rating in realism
about a seven eight just based on the
the type of weapons the tactics the
chaos the building constructions it's
pretty real
White
I think this is an important scene
because one of the biggest myths that TV
and movies show about Urban Warfare is
that it's just infantry or soldiers
shooting their weapons major Urban
battles are tanks artillery Engineers
infantry they're full-scale battles in
concrete now the damage that the tank
does to the building that is unlikely
that the just the whole face of the
building is going to fall off it's going
to do a lot of damage and that's why you
have a tank because a tank is mobile
protected Firepower it has that giant
gun that can punch through that problem
which is concrete and cover but in this
scene that they're all tracers it's
almost like a Star Wars ray gun they
won't all be like that
there's actually a myth that tanks are
not helpful in urban whatever they're
too vulnerable but actually the history
of urban Warfare if you go into a major
urban fight and you don't have a tank
you're wrong but the problem is that the
tank can't go by itself and the Infantry
can't go by itself and as we see in the
scene the Infantry work to protect the
tank and then the tank protects the
Infantry but tanks are vulnerable as you
see here the Germans shoot from below
where the tank can shoot in the basement
come here
the size needed to take a town or a
village or a city all depends on what
the enemy it is that you're they're
facing and I think they really didn't
know for that street I think that looked
about right absolutely where you combine
a tank section always two tanks with an
infantry platoon or something to clear a
street like that before you discover
where the enemy is outside of the lasers
of the rounds this is a very realistic
thing of high intention combat and the
combined arms that you need so I give it
a nine
[Music]
oh you need to pause oh one thing that I
I can't help myself on the scene is that
everyone walks up to the wall and just
sticks their rifle over the top of the
wall that's absolutely what you don't do
you're just putting a flag up the same
way you are I don't have any problem
with them moving to the rooftops
um this is a hasty attack two different
buildings that's great it gives you
converging fires so fire them down from
two different directions they can cover
more of the courtyards the scene in this
movie is is based on the real battle of
muscle that happened in 2017 one of the
biggest battles really since World War
II a hundred thousand Security Forces
against a entrenched Isis enemy force
that had to be cleared out
that's actually pretty realistic you
open an attack like that with your
biggest weapon year we call it the most
casually producing weapons Duds do
happen the way they usually get around
that is you have more than a single
point of failure more than one big
weapon or like they do here which is
actually accurate once that Duds that's
it your surprise is gone attack
foreign
it's actually pretty complex what
they're trying to do because they have
moving forces with other elements
shooting down that they have to know and
watch very closely on when to turn their
fire off as you advance that's in some
ways the way I would teach it as well um
that's as they're maneuvering in while
another person is holding them down
booby traps are are very popular in
urban Warfare pictures on the wall any
and everything could be potentially
booby trapped we see it right now in the
Ukraine war when Ukraine takes back
their own house their territories from
the Russians but you have to be hyper
aware of all those booby traps for sure
one is it's just awareness in every
Soldier not to move and displace things
and then we have bomb sticking dogs that
we'll bring in I'm going to actually
give it around a five six just some of
it's a little off
yeah he'll be on the footwalk over the
gutter
we'll take him out from behind
the underground is a huge component of
that three-dimensional aspects of urban
Warfare many cities have cities under
the cities and in battles like this
which this movie is based on the Battle
of Stalingrad which was called the rat
War because there was such a prevalent
Underground
yes that's a possible Urban sniper
positions the characters on both sides
are Loosely tied to real snipers that
were prevalent in the Battle of
Stalingrad who were known to like put
themselves in the barrels and the
ventilation shafts the cat and a mouse
between the two snipers
that didn't happen
we do train soldiers to use the
environment and there is some aspect of
manipulating light and smoke that's the
real thing right reflective lights in
the mirror but you don't know what a
sniper is and unlikely that you're going
to have that ability to Blind that so no
don't don't do that I want to give it a
higher one because it is point out the
underground whipper aspect about the
realism of the actual this happening
around a three I guess
that's pretty about as real as it gets
the IED or the improvised explosive
device is the weapon of the last 20 plus
years the invisible enemy that you you
could invite back against
the m250 Cal this is still used today
it's very effective uh large machine gun
that has the size of bullet and
penetration of concrete that you'd want
where other weapons might not the
accuracy of what the bullets were doing
to the building looked pretty pretty
accurate some of them you can tell
aren't penetrating he didn't shoot that
many bullets at that wall to create that
level of a sprawling and honeycombing of
that well
the tactics there are pretty sound where
you have the machine gun covering an
upper level while the Infantry of
maneuvering lower so there's control
there and positioning themselves to
enter that building where they know the
enemy is
I can't say that that kicking of the
door is not real it's called The Mule
Kick I wish the movies would stop
showing it because it's not effective
but I have found many soldiers trying it
uh but it's not the most Force you can
put by kicking in that door you you want
to face the door
that's an unfortunate but very realistic
aspect of that scenario and that chaos
of when the soldier enters the room but
control did not just firing at everybody
but then you have a scared frantic
civilians even approaching you making
the soldier feel very unsafe that's a
very realistic and impactful traumatic
situation that is urban Warfare so if we
were to take out the mule kick I would
give that scene a 10. my favorite Urban
Warfare show or scene is actually saving
a Private Ryan the aspect of the sniper
and basically using a casualty to draw
more people out is my favorite movie
scene of urban Warfare thanks for
watching if you enjoyed this video why
not click on the video above
oh
foreign
[Music]